all right so though I enjoyed the flash
I think that there are definitely issues
with the movie as a whole though I think
that the second act works really really
well where things start to fall apart is
towards the end of the film watching the
battle against sod should feel like it's
a big moment but something about it just
seems to fall flat Michael Shannon's
sins come out and said that he didn't
find the film that fulfilling and I feel
this is something we can feel as we
watch the film too now upon thinking
about it I actually realized that zod's
very similar Thanos in endgame but I
think the ladder works well or as this
one doesn't throughout the video we're
going to be going through all the
similarities that the pair shares
story-wise and saying why one worked
whilst the other didn't full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't checked it out
then I highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoy the video please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day by the way huge thank you for
clicking this I'm your host Paul now
let's dive into it
now as I touched upon before both
actually share a lot of similarities I
want to talk about how the final two
acts work I think you'll see them too
both films center around people
traveling back in time and this allows
an old threat to become a brand new one
both villains don't interact with the
hero until that final Act and both at
one point be the heroes that they're
facing the heroes have to do something
crazy in order to beat the villain and
two Legacy characters die as things are
closing out Batman dies in Flash or as
it's Tonya on end game and this is used
to add some emotion to the film now
Thanos and end game works or as I feel
like zodges Falls slightly sure and when
we get into it hopefully you'll see why
that's the case now the first criticism
I have is that Zod doesn't really up the
stakes and instead when he comes back
they simply stay the same in endgame we
watched as the heroes going back in time
gave Thanos the new knowledge that his
prior Planet failed thus when he came
back to the future he'd up the stakes
even more and was now gonna wipe out all
of the universe entirely he destroyed
the time machine had planted his
daughter in the group and also had the
potential to get the stones back on the
opposite side of this zod's Mission
still stays the same and what he wants
to do is terraform the planet this is
something we've already seen a man of
steel and there's the threat they're
facing feels like it's been lessened in
the case of Thanos you feel he instant
regret the heroes too because in trying
to save the universe they've created
something worse had they left things
alone then things wouldn't be on the
knife's edge like this Raz with Zod it's
something we've already seen fail now we
don't know it's a fixed point on a first
watch but going into that battle it
makes it feel less threatening now in
the flash what they do is reveal that
he's killed Kalel and thus the odds are
slightly against the heroes due to him
no longer being there however Supergirl
has all the same power set that he did
and there's two versions of the flash
running around out there as well thus we
don't really feel the danger that we
should whereas with Thanos you get more
of a threat having not experienced this
before we don't know what to expect or
ask amount of Steel battles 10 years old
now now the next plot point they share
is that they both beat the heroes and at
this point the heroes have to step it up
in endgame we get the big portal scene
where everyone comes together and this
is probably one of the strongest scenes
in the MCU it shows the heroes coming
together as one united front and facing
down against the biggest villain that
they've ever faced it really feels like
a triumphant moment as these are people
we watch die and this them coming back
hits us on several levels for several
different reasons not only are we happy
to see them back but we're excited to
see what's next and they then paid off
with the Avengers Assemble line now what
happens in The Flash is Barry goes back
in time many tries to kill Zod by
turning back the clock now this is
slightly lessened as it takes away the
stakes because because we feel like
Barry can just repeat this till he wins
now obviously in the movie as we said we
learned this isn't the case and that
zod's Victory is seen as a fixed point a
version of Barry goes back until it
destroys him as a person unless he loses
himself in trying to change the past now
in these scenes we get the death of a
beloved character which comes in the
form of Bruce and Tony Stark we watch
Keaton die twice which I feel robs us of
the emotion because we're watching
something happen that we know just can
be changed plus we have the weird
emotion of Barry just saying no and his
sacrifice means nothing the two times
that he does it on the second one the
giant kryptonians knocked down but he
gets back up so again it leads nowhere
on the other side of this Tony actually
kills the bad guy and takes out all his
forces which cost the guy his life the
sacrifice feels more impactful because
it actually means something unless his
final actor's way to it or as The Flash
doesn't now Beyond this there's also the
two ways the scenes go which leaves one
feeling meaningful or as the others not
in any game we watch Thanos being
defeated or as in the flash we don't see
what happens his death's never shown on
screen we never get a final fight and in
the end he's simply erased by the
timeline changing it robs us of the
payoff that we should get in the third
Act and we never get that fist pump
moment when we see that he's brought
down now in the flashpoint comic they
did something with the third act villain
that took the opposite approach and
allowed us to get a chair moment so in
Flashpoint things descended into war
that just like the movie was gonna
destroy the planet when all hope seemed
lost we learned what was going on and
why the world itself had ended up this
way now For Better or Worse Flashpoint
didn't tell us Barry had traveled back
in time and instead he just woke up to
find that the world had changed the
mystery of the entire thing was what had
made it alter and clues of the reverse
flash was seen throughout the work this
made us think that it was him who
changed things and he showed up at the
end to reveal the actual truth very much
like a third act villain he came out of
nowhere and told Barry that he was the
one who actually changed the timeline
now the flash lets us know from the off
that it's Barry who altered things so
this revealer comes at the end can't be
given how it is however I don't think
that the mystery would have worked all
that well in general anyway because
we've had it in that and the team TV
show as well how about what happens next
is something that was missing from The
Flash and the reverse flash is shot in
the head from behind by Batman it saves
Barry's life and also makes Batman feel
important whereas we don't get that
moment happening with sod now I know
some of you probably think if he'd done
that then they'd not need to travel back
but even in defeating him the world
still started ending the real moment
that broke everything was Barry saving
his mother which caused Outlander and
damascara to go head-to-head with each
other because of this he realized he
still had to go back and change things
in the past and they I think that they
could have somehow worked this into
flash they could have had that being the
breaking point whereas in the case of
this Barry only goes back because he
can't defeat sod I think having Zodi off
screen does a real disservice to the
movie and I had the same problem with
how Ben Affleck's taken two these
characters don't really feel like they
get any finality they're just wiped out
with Barry changing things in time and
like I said I like the flash but I think
a couple of changes could have made the
Final Act way better I gave the film a
good review but comparing it to how
endgame handles its returning villains I
feel that it fails in comparison here
the focus is given to Barry more than
the bad guy but just a couple of tweaks
could have made Zod feel like a bigger
threat instead we have most of the
complaints about that and even Michael
Shannon saying he didn't enjoy it so in
summary if you're ever writing a movie
or want to make it so your surprise
Legacy villains impactful that have made
a list of what you need to do firstly up
the stakes so that the villain feels
like they're infinitely more dangerous
than the threat that's been handled
before have them beat the heroes like
both these characters do I've been
slagging them off but I did like the The
Flash did that and that takes us to the
next steps the next had the heroes step
it up but keep this all connected to the
fight itself people want to see the
villain being defeated and that's where
things should remain like how they
handled it in Flashpoint if you're
sacrificing Legacy characters then have
them beat the villain so their death
feels meaningful instead of having it
wiped to the side by it not going
anywhere give us a moment in which the
threads taken out and if you have to go
beyond that at least let us feel the
victory otherwise you might end up with
a film that feels like it's a bit of a
downer where good people die for nothing
and we get stuck with George Clooney I'm
just kidding you I liked it I genuinely
did I just think a couple of tweaks
could have made these moments go from
good to going into great would give us a
better film Beyond what we got in my
opinion and just make those scenes with
sod feel even better than they are
anyway let us know your thoughts below
and if you prefer the way they handled
Zod then I'd love to hear your point of
view too remember it's all comic book
movies and we talk about this stuff
because we're passionate and not because
we hate it so if you love it may I'd
love to hear why now hopefully I'll see
you on the next one and if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below as a thank you you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes towards helping videos like this
get made we also have our merch store
over at Zero edition comb which sells
lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and
more we've just launched a secret
Invasion slash Pulp Fiction inspired
shirt so if you want to head over there
and help us out then the links in the
description now if you want something
else to watch we've been covering secret
Invasion itself so if you if you're
interested in that show then go and
check them out personally I'm loving it
got lots of theories about what's going
on so definitely head over there right
after this without the way huge thank
you for sticking us through the video
I'll be important I'll see you next time
take care peace